[음악]
네 안녕하세요 빌사남입니다
하나은행에서 최근에 그 부자들
대상으로 리포트를 발행한게 있어요
그래서 오늘은 그 리포트를 보면서
부자들이
어떤 자산을 가지고 있고 그리고
앞으로
어떤 자산의 투자하려고 하는지 저랑
같이
분석을 해보도록 하겠습니다 지금이
리포트에서 정의를 좀 이렇게 했어요
부자는
금융 자산이 10억 이상 보유자를
이제 부자라고 정의를 했고 그 중에
슈퍼리치를
금융자산 100억 이상 또는
총자산
300억 이상을 보유한 부자를
슈퍼리치라고 정의를 했습니다 그리고
대중부유층은 1억에서 10억 이상
금융 자산을 보유한 사람 그리고 일반
대중은 1억 미만의 보유자를 일반
대중이라고 정의를 했습니다 어 그래서
지금 슈퍼리치 1인당
총 자산 평균이 323억
원입니다 21년 정도가 373억
원인데 부동산 가격이 좀 떨어지면서
자산 규모가 좀 줄어들었고
근데 여기서 좀 보셔야 될게 금융
자산 비율이 좀 높아졌어요
연평균 소득이 이분들이 12억원이래요
그리고 직업을 보니까
기업을 경영하는 분들이 다수입니다
그리고 총자산의 50%가
금융자산이며 불항기의
현금이나 예금 비중을 크게 확대한
것으로 좀 보여집니다 그리고 공무원
분들은 거의 없고요
회사원 분들도 좀 비중이 났고 그래서
대부분 좀 기업을 운영하시는 그런
분들이
슈퍼리치가 좀 많았습니다 21년도에는
금융자산이 뭐 한 40% 그다음
부동산이 한 60% 가까이 됐는데
그게 지금 5:5 비율 그리고
금융자산 비율이 더 높아졌어요 그리고
주식 비중이 좀 낮추고
현금이나 예금 비중이 높아졌습니다
그걸 작년에 하셨어요
작년에 보면은 좀 이렇게 금리가 급
정확하게 올라가거나 좀 상황이 변할
걸 알고 미리
현금이나 예금 비중을 되게 좀 높인
것으로 좀 보여집니다 그래서 뭐 작년
같은 경우에
슈퍼리치 분들은 한 70% 정도가
수익을 냈어요 일반 부자는 66%
대중부유층들은 한 57% 그래서
슈퍼리치 분들이 좀 대부분 수익을
많이 냈습니다 그리고 또 이제
실물 경기 전망인데 대부분 다 이제
부정적으로 봤어요
2023년이 한 80% 정도 다 이제
부정적이라고 봤고
향후 투자
의향이 높은 자산 1순위
역시 부동산입니다 부동산 비율이 제일
높고 그 다음 예금이나 주식 펀드
신탁 이렇게 비율이 좀 높고요
부동산에 투자의 장점이라고
생각하시는게 대부분 다 자산을
안정적으로 유지하고 보존하는 기능이
높기 때문에 그래서 부동산을
투자한다고 합니다
장기적인 관점에서 다른 투자 자산에
비해 투 수익률이 우수하고 그리고
임대수익 창출이 한 19% 정도
됩니다 그래서
임대수익보다는
조금 자산을 안정적으로 유지를 하거나
보관하는 측면에서
투자를 한 것으로 좀 보여집니다
재미로 보는 이제 부자의 mbti인데
estj가 많아요 그리고
ispj 저는 해당이 안 되는데
눈에 띄었던게 해외 주식 비중이 좀
높았어요 슈퍼리치 분들이 그래서 일반
부자나 대중부유층보다
슈퍼리치 분들은 한 16% 정도 해외
주식을 좀 많이 했습니다 그리고
여기서 또 하나 보셔야 될게
2022년에 수익의 긍정적 부정적
영향을 준 금융자산이 뭐냐 보니까
일단 긍정적으로 영향을 준 거는
예금이나 채권 그 다음에 펀드신탁
부정적을 영향을 준 금융자산은 제일
높은게 주식입니다 그래서 주식이 이제
작년에 좀 많이 떨어지면서 부정적인
영향을 좀 많이
준 것으로 좀
가지고 그 다음에 펀드 신탁이나
가상화폐 뭐 이런 이런 순으로 되고
있습니다
근데 2023년
경기 불황을 예상하는 슈퍼리치 투자
의향은 1위는 주식 주식을 투자할
거라는 분들이 좀 많고요 그 두
번째가 이제 부동산입니다
금융자산이 100억원 이상인 슈퍼리치
분들은
매입을 한다면
빌딩 아니면 대형 아파트 순으로
투자한다는
의견이 좀 많았습니다 대부분
슈퍼리치의 절반 이상은
빌딩을
50억 이상
금액을 보실 필요가 있어요
50억 이상 그 다음에 다음으로
40평형 이상의 대형 아파트를
고려했다이 이유는
슈퍼리치의 자산의 확대 가장 크게
기여한 부동산 순위와 일치한다 대형
아파트는
실제 주택가격 하락과
금리와 무관하게
2022년에도
현금 부자 수요로 인해 신고가의
거래되기도 했으며
2019년 11월 그리고
단 한 번의 하락 없이 상승 곡선을
그리고 있다 그래서 저도 보면은 이런
대형 아파트
계속 최고가 갱신되는 거를 보고
있습니다 최근에는 한남더월도 그렇고
뭐 원베일리도 뭐 펜트하우스가 이제
100억원 좀 안전하다고 많이
생각하시는 거 같아요
2023년에 부동산 매입 계획이
약간 반반인 것 같습니다 그래서
없다가 51 그다음 이따가 49%
근데 부동산보다 일단 주식을 좀
투자할 생각들이 더 많으신 거 같아요
아무래도 많이 떨어져 있다 보니까
어떻게 슈퍼리치가 됐냐 어쩌다
보니라는 답이 많대요 부모의 교육이나
가정의 분위기로 인해 자연스럽게
관심을 가진 경우가
슈퍼리치에서 제일 많습니다 아무래도
교육이 되게 좀 중요한 것 같아요
그래서 좀 우리나라가 좀 사교육이
되게 좀 열풍이지 않나 뭐 이런
생각을 좀 하고요 일반 부자 분들이나
대중부유층 분들은 부양을 하기 위해서
관심을 가진 경우가 많고
분들은 부모의 교육이나 가정 분위기로
인해서 여기 또 관심있게 봐야 되는게
월 소득의 절반은 저축한다라고 합니다
슈퍼리치 분들은
월 소득의 절반 이상 그러니까
57%를 다 저축하세요 일반 부자
분들은 소비를 좀 많이 하시고
대중부유층들도 소비를 좀 많이 하고요
그리고 부를 일구는 방법에 대해서도
인터뷰를 했는데
슈퍼리치 분들은
96%가
투자를 통해서
큰 부를 이룰 계획이다 이렇게 했고
금융자산이 1억 미만인 분들은 다
이제 근로소득으로
번다라는
의견들이 좀 많았어요
금액이 커질수록 다 투자를 통해서
돈을 번을 깼다는
의견들이 많았습니다 그리고 또 하나
유심히 보셔야 될게 슈퍼리치의 부의
이전 계획 부를 어떻게 이전할 건지
이것도 이제 설문조사를 했는데
부동산보다는
현금이나 예금
직렬을 더 선호한다고 합니다 부동산을
만약에 증여할 때는
모형보다는 상업용 이거를 되게 좀
유심히 보셔야 될 필요가 있는데
상업용을 왜 이제 증여를 많이
생각하냐면 부담부 증여를 많이 하려고
합니다 그래서 대출까지 이제 같이
증여를 하면
절세 측면에서도
조금 유리한 부분이 있습니다
근데 이제 일반 부자 분들은 주거용을
더
증여를 하려고 계획 중이시고
2023년 어 부자 분들의
경기 전망과 투자계획 그래서 일단
대체적으로 다 부정적입니다
작년보다 더 부정적이고
지난해 이어 올해도 자산 구성을 이제
유지하겠다라는
응답이 절반 이상이었습니다
2023년
목표 수익률은 한 5에서 10%
정도의 집중하는 것 같습니다
향후 투자의향이 높은 자산 1순위
부동산 3명 중에 한 명은 올해 매입
계획이라고 합니다
첫 번째가 부동산이고 그 다음에 이제
예금 주식 펀드 뭐 이런 식으로 그냥
부자 분들은 이제 중소형 아파트에
되게 관심이 많고
40평 미만의 아파트
근데 자산이 있으신 분들은 대형
아파트나 빌딩 금액대가 좀 높은 빌딩
금액대가 좀 높은 빌딩들이 거래가 좀
될 수 있겠다 1 2년 전만 해도
50억 미만의 꼬마빌딩이 거래가 좀
많이 됐지만 이제 앞으로 같은
경우에는 좀 이제 금액대가 좀 높은
빌딩들 거래량이 좀 더 높아지지
않을까 그리고 이런 대형 아파트들의
거래가 그래도 좀 이루어지지 않을까
뭐 이런 식으로 좀 예상을 하게
됩니다 자산가 분들의 뭔가 자금을
묶어두는 종착역은 부동산이라고
생각한다라는
얘기들이 좀 많아요 이걸 좀 되게
유심히 볼 필요가 있는 것 같아요
부자들이 생각하는 부동산 투자의 장점
자산을 안정적으로 보존하기 위해서
유지하거나 보존하기 위해서 투자를
한대요 그래서 어떻게 보면 자산을
파킹 하려고 좀 많이 사는 거 같아요
그래서 그런 의미로 봤을 때 제가
계속 주요 지역에 살아난 이유가
임대수 사실 얼마 나오진 않아도이
자산을 파킹 하려는 분들이 많이
있어요
리포트에 보는 거와 같이 그래서 제가
계속 주요 지역에 사라고 하는 겁니다
여기 보면 임대수익 창출 보고 사시는
분들이이 파킹 하려는 분들보다 비율이
낮아요
장기적인 관점에서는 다른 투자 자산과
비해
투자 수익률이 우수하다 그리고 이제
부동산 고수의
투자 비법 전체적으로 다 얘기하는게
부동산 투자 핵심은 타이밍과 입지다
압구정의 건물 셋째가 있고
도산공원 일대에 1000억원대
부동산을 보유하곤 손님이 있다 이분은
다른 지역에 투자하는 사람은 잘
이해하지 못한다 그리고 똑같은 돈을
투자하더라도
항상
입지를 잘 선별해야
된다고 말씀하신다 그리고 언제라도
다시 팔 수 있는 것을 사라고 제가
항상 얘기하는 겁니다 이거
항상 입지를 잘 선정해야 되고 지금
같은 시기는 더 그렇습니다 그리고
다시 할 일 할 수 있는
황금성이 높은 부동산을 살았고 제가
항상 얘기하잖아요
강남은 항상 비싸지만 그 기회를 사야
한다는 것이다
되게 부자
분들에 대한 생각을 여러분들이 그래도
좀 그 아실 필요가 있는 거 같아요
뭐 이미 부자이신 분들도 있고 그래서
부자 분들이 지금 보통 어떤 자세를
좀 많이 몰려 있고 그리고 이분들이
앞으로 좀
어떤 생각들을 하는지 여러분들이 좀
보고 판단하실 필요가 있습니다 이걸
토대로 앞으로 뭐 부동산 투자
계획이라든지 뭐 어떤 자산에 투자해야
되는지가 나와 있기 때문에 좀 저희
구독자분들은 이거를 좀 유심히 보실
필요가 있지 않을까네 이렇게 생각을
합니다